lastly you were keeping contact with the
leaders all throughout this event and
you're definitely trying uh even
signaling not playing the Berlin playing
Asics trying to keep the game going
against kiril and you had some chances
in that one as well but you did finish
with an important Victory some your day
for us
yeah I mean it's it's been a pretty
tough day
but uh you know I just take one day at a
time take chances whenever it appears
and uh
just play hired me I'm kind of
regretting
going for such a complex variation
against anishikiri you know and the
white pieces there it was a good chance
but I got over ambitious and then he
punished me
for for that but I'm just trying to play
some
good chess you know if if possible
speaking of good chess let's analyze
this game the final one against Burger
Bogdan was having a pretty decent event
he was definitely upsetting some people
yeah I mean he had very bad days and
he's had some good days like the first
day he lost all three rapid games yes
and then after that he recovered uh also
here he won two in a row at some point
so it's been a like when when he's in
good form he can play really well yeah
full respect to him but he's very well
prepared in the opening so that's why I
decided to you're trying to take him out
early on yeah go for this line yeah
because uh he's
been well prepared in one e45 opening he
made an easy draw against Magnus in the
better off so it's pretty well versed
I'm a bit surprised that he plays Knight
after eater with white when he such a
good tradition but
gotta mix up his
uh opening real early I thought I
thought black should try to prevent
Bishop Dieter and E4 by like playing
Knight A5 here for that Bishop Leader by
Bishop E4 maybe bishop to E4 yeah yeah
that's the entire plan
so actually I played this against him
before back in 2019 in Gibraltar okay so
but then he makes up his move order and
after E4 he thought for so E5 is already
a mistake well if I was a blunder yes so
then he what's the point behind it
because the cv4 looks
aggressive right yeah because now I get
the D5 I mean I think this is just
losing for black after I'm gonna play
Bishop F5 let's say sacrifice the pawn
pick it up later but you just have this
amazing attack yeah yep uh black always
has to be a bit careful because the Rook
is on the same
directly attacking the enemy Queen big
pin yes ff35 started shaking his head a
lot and then he spent two and a half
minutes
but there was no way to uh prepare the
situation I was very happy when I fact
Knight takes E5 I guess maybe it's not
the best move but when you have two
Bishops and a few Pawns I think I think
Knight takes E5 is actually the best
from a practical perspective for sure
maybe even objectively yeah probably
because the Bishops are just too strong
they just want to grab a pawn as much as
possible but actually E5 wasn't mistaken
I guess
seven
he could have defended uh better yes but
still the position even here remains
very difficult for him yeah but it's
been an interesting uh you know day for
me now obviously very happy to beat
Magnus I'm assume you're gonna want to
have a syringe very badly after that but
maybe you should thank me actually
because he got very motivated after he
got angry after he lost against you
that's true yeah yeah he had uh you know
bug dance tried to slow hit him down a
bit I believe right but then after that
he just got on on a roll yeah absolutely
well with one day to go you are one
point behind Duda have a point behind
um Magnus what do you need to do
tomorrow to win this event because I'm
sure these are your ambitions
well if I played like I did today I
think I
okay winning first place is not easy
because
you got Magnus I I thought Magnus will
be in bad form after the first couple of
days but I decided to
uh pick up like I thought before this
event
like maybe hasn't look at chess for an
entire month but apparently he has so I
feel very difficult to never safe to
come with him out yeah yeah if you win
if you score plus five on on Blitz on
one day
and then you score another good then
it's very difficult to stop you like
last year remember Fabiano had Bluffton
it's just
unimaginable to me how anyone can score
plus 10 on 18 games but I think if I
play like I did today uh you know just
try to avoid too many Planters and play
some good chest and maybe I'll have a a
chance uh
because I think other than my game
against Anish Geary my games today were
pretty okay definitely a good plan
Wesley and we'll let you go get some
rest and we'll see it once get some
sleeping okay get some sleeping all
right
guys back to you in the studio thank you
Wesley and thank you Christian I mean